a southwest pilot finds himself on the
hot seat after allegedly speaking the
most vulgar of all phrases let's go
brandon plus joe biden's poles are in
the toilet and colin kaepernick compares
the nfl combine to actual slavery i'm
bench bureau this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with
vpny trust visit expressvpn.com
ben well you know those pirates who are
constantly sailing the seven seas they
weren't doing so in search of us dollars
because those dollars didn't exist
number one and number two would have
been increasingly worthless over time if
they had instead they were searching for
doubloons right they wanted the gold
well if you are concerned about the
future of the united states dollar the
way that pirates used to be perhaps you
should be checking out birch gold today
because here's the thing it was recently
announced that social security benefits
are going to increase by 5.9 in january
that's the highest increase in 40 years
this is the government admitting
inflation is out of control and yet the
left is still pushing through trillions
more in spending so how are you
protecting your savings from inflation i
protect mine with gold and silver from
birch gold now an incentive for you to
do so this month when you text ben to 47
47 47 and purchase precious metals with
birch gold by december 23rd you'll get
free silver for every five thousand
dollars you invest and yes you can
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by precious metals that
qualifies as well birch gold has that a
plus breeding with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews
thousands of happy customers including
me text ben 247 47 47 for your free no
obligation information kit on holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account and to claim your free silver
with qualifying purchase by december
23rd text ban
247-4747 protect your savings today with
an asset that will not devalue the way
that paper money does instead try your
hand with precious metals to expend 47
47 47 to get started alrighty so
right now the polls for joseph r biden
are just horrific they're just really
bad here's the thing democrats have a
real problem on their hands because joe
biden has pursued radical policies that
no one wanted for him again i can't say
it enough his mandate coming in was one
be not alive and two be moderate and he
has achieved only one of these things he
has a zombie wandering around doing the
work of bernie sanders and this is like
the worst combo because you've got a guy
who's not alive but also is scaring you
right he's not like he's not like an
inanimate object that's not scary he's
not you know just a just a jug on the
floor or something instead he's actually
wandering around searching for brains in
the in the mold of progressive radicals
and so americans are increasingly not
liking this at all right now there's an
nbc poll it shows 71 percent of
americans believe the united states is
on the wrong track uh oh biden's
approval rating stands at 42 that is
down seven points from august that's the
last time their survey was taken the
poll shows a majority of americans
disapprove of the president's job
performance 54
giving biden a thumbs down for his first
nine months in office only 37 of
americans believe biden is competent and
effective compared with 50 percent who
don't believe that
only 37 percent believe that biden can
handle a crisis with 47
saying he cannot which means
his actual floor is not 42 his actual
floor is like 37 which is just
horrific for him especially because the
hopes of the democratic party are so
pegged to him personally nobody's big on
his agenda but the idea was that he was
going to be personally a popular guy
right he's inoffensive and he's
sympathetic empathetic grandpa joe right
he's he's the guy who's going to come in
he's going to comfort you and tell his
stories about beau and then it turns out
that afghanistan killed all of that he
didn't seem empathetic anymore he seemed
like a jerk he seemed like a belligerent
jackass and because of that americans
were like okay he's belligerent and he's
nasty and he's incompetent and he's
senile so that is a very very bad
combination for joe biden and you're
seeing it reflected across the board the
polling numbers for democrats right now
are just brutal issue by issue
republicans have massive advantages
issue by issue right now republicans are
up by 27 points in terms of who you
trust to deal with border security
in dealing with the economy republicans
are up by 18 points in dealing with the
economy
that is that is the biggest number in
the i'm looking at right now that is the
biggest number in history of the nbc
news poll that number republicans up by
18 points huge huge advantage for
republicans dealing with immigration
again they're up by a huge a huge number
when it comes to education democrats who
traditionally been up by like 20 points
in that area are only up by about 10.
democrats are up a lot in global warming
but here's the thing no one cares about
global warming so who cares
when it comes to every major issue that
americans care about republicans are up
big in this new nbc news poll and that
is a disaster for them
republicans are up massively when it
comes to controlling inflation 24 points
with regard to controlling inflation
dealing with crime republicans are up by
22 points dealing with crime dealing
with national security republicans up 21
points dealing with national security
how about election security right now
we're talking about the january 6th
stuff democrats are only at one point so
that whole january 6 talking point that
elections are going to be stolen by the
evil republicans no one actually thinks
that's true and no one cares
it's a basically even split
democrats are ahead on one issue and one
issue only by any significant margin and
that of course is climate change which
no one has is a top priority in the
united states right now
not just that new poll from abc news
shows roughly seven in 10 americans
know virtually nothing about what
exactly democrats are negotiating about
but of the americans who do more
americans say that they don't like the
bill than say that they do like the bill
the new abc news ipsos poll found a
plurality 32 percent of americans think
the bills would hurt people like them if
they became law only 25 think it would
help them
about 2 in 10 18
said that they think the bills will make
no difference 24 said they didn't know
even among democrats fewer than half
think the two bills would help people
like them 47
a quarter of democrats think it'll make
no difference
don't know how it would impact their
lives
okay so these are just disastrous
numbers for democrats across the board
so if you believe that them passing this
bill is going to save them rongo it is
not them passing build back better will
not save them it will harm them because
they are throwing money at an inflation
problem
only about half of independents approve
of biden's handling of climate change
okay but on other issues economic
recovery gun violence crime and taxes
independence approval hovers around four
in ten he is below 40
on gun violence afghanistan and
immigration he's at 31
on immigration
fewer than two-thirds of democrats
approve of biden's handling of gun
violence why because crime is spiked in
the major cities only 62 percent of
democrats approve of biden's handling of
afghanistan this is the abc news poll
again a separate poll
on immigration only 54 percent of
democrats approve of biden immigration
these are abysmal numbers i mean
honestly these are numbers that are way
worse than what trump had because biden
ain't even holding his own base his own
base is looking at him cross-eyed
and joe biden has no good answer on this
so he was at this this g20 summit
so he decided to cross the seas
and spew a bunch of carbon
in order to jabber about climate change
with a bunch of other people who aren't
going to do anything about climate
change and uh and then apparently we
looked scant at by uh by greta dunberg
will be very disappointed in joe biden
so here is joe biden a decrepit
daughtering president
a top aides decrepit daughtering
authoritarian presidency saying that he
has no good answer on these polls
the polls are going to go up and down
and up and down they were high early
then they got medium then went back up
and now they're low well look this is
look look at every other president the
same thing has happened but that's not
why i ran i didn't rent run to determine
how well i'm going to do in the polls i
ran to make sure that i followed through
what i said i would do as president
united states
yeah man uh no not everybody's polls
looked like this obama's polls didn't
look like this
they didn't his predecessor in the
democratic party his polls did not look
like that okay so this is what is
underlying the media's sudden obsession
with the fact that people really don't
like biden to the extent that they are
now chanting let's go brandon
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about the fact that let's say
let's say that your family is really
lacking cash and so you decide to take
part in some sort of odd gambling
scenario where you're going to go and
you're going to play children's games
for the possibility of winning a lot of
money but the downside is you might get
shot right those are the two choices
you're going to win this giant pile of
money or
you're going to be shot to death well
before you enter the arena you might
think very seriously about getting some
life insurance policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius in fact you could save 300
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy unions
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call that
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
it's super easy go to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price and when you're ready to
apply that policy genius team will
handle the paperwork and scheduling for
free head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
all right so
as you all know as i'm sure you have
heard the chant let's go brandon has
become very common across the country
now you'll recall the reason that let's
go brandon went viral in the first place
is because there is a nascar race in
which a driver named brandon brown won
the race and he was being interviewed
after the race by a sports reporter and
in the background people were not
chanting let's go brandon they were
chanting bleep joe biden
believe being the f word right f joe
biden this is what they were chanting
and the reporter trying to pass this off
as a non-obscene chant said listen to
that crowd brandon they're all saying
let's go brandon and it was super funny
because you can hear right in the
background the people chanting f joe
biden okay you can hear it and then you
can hear the media in real time trying
to spin it as like a pro brandon cheer
so this has become sort of the more
innocent meme of f joe biden right when
you want to say f joe biden but you
don't want to be vulgar instead you say
let's go brandon it also happens to be
kind of a hilarious in-joke about the
incompetence and stupidity of an insular
media that are constantly attempting to
spin away the fact that people do not
like joe biden and this is the whole
thing guys
if for the media for the democratic
party joe biden must remain personally
popular or the democrats are toast
remember the entire 2020 campaign was
not run on issues on the issues donald
trump won on personality joe biden won
not because people love joe biden but
because he's not donald trump and so
ever since then democrats have basically
been relying on two things not being
trump and maybe maybe you'll develop a
certain sense of warmth for joe biden
well here's the thing nobody has a sense
of warmth for joe biden
nobody thinks that joe biden
is what he was billed as this this
empathetic
elderly statesman who's gonna massage
your shoulders while he comforts you
about your your life issues like nobody
thinks of joe biden that way and so when
the ire raises with joe biden it scares
the living hell out of the democrats as
it should especially because they don't
have anybody waiting in the wings
right the person who is next in line is
even more unpopular than joe biden
kamala harris
the the cackling
politician
who
literally begins laughing randomly if
asked a difficult question and is so
fake
that she makes i can't believe it's not
butter seem like the genuine article
okay that that's
she is she's air sats authenticity and
and very clearly so and she's the spam
of of breakfast mates i mean
nobody likes kamala harris so you got
joe biden here and then behind him you
got kamala harris and they're like oh my
god
really and then they were trying to prop
up to judge but it turns out that guy
went on paternity leave for two months
for
who knows and um and then no one even
noticed so democrats have a real world
of hurt coming from them it's not as
they have a deep venture
and so this scares them let's go let's
go brandon is scary to them you have to
understand that let's go brandon is is
even scarier to them than the time that
that rodeo clown
dons an obama mask and the entire media
activated because here's the other thing
about joe biden if joe biden is not
personally popular if people don't like
joe biden the democrats cannot claim it
is because of racism when people didn't
like barack obama's agenda the democrats
kept claiming and so did obama that it
was because the american people are
actually secretly racist when it was
hillary clinton the media had a
convenient excuse
it turns out that you are a vicious
brutal sexist in in fact the media would
have an easier time with people not
liking kamala harris and not liking joe
biden because if people don't like
kamala harris the media just says that
you're racist and sexist but if you
don't like joe biden who is whiter than
the back of this sheet of paper i mean
joe biden makes me look like a person of
color
if you don't like joe biden it turns out
maybe you just don't like joe biden and
you don't like his agenda and this is
scary for democrats because if you don't
like joe biden you don't like his agenda
what's the alternative okay so all of
this came to a head over the weekend
because allegedly there was a pilot
on southwest airlines who came on the
loudspeaker and as a joke said let's go
brandon
which is just horrific i mean just
brutal and horrific and how could it
happen
okay so according to a reporter from the
associated press named colleen long
this is the only allegation we have on
friday morning on a southwest flight
from houston to albuquerque the pilot
signed off his greeting over the public
address system with the phrase to
audible gasps from some passengers
people just audibly gasping oh the pearl
clutching they're clutching those pearls
so hard they actually turn them into
into pearls they they clutch them so
hard they turn them into diamonds they
clutch them so hard
southwest said in a statement the
airline quote takes pride in providing a
welcoming comfortable and respectful
environment and behavior from any
individual that is divisive or offensive
is not condoned
veteran gop admaker jim and osensi had
no qualms about the coded crudity
calling it hilarious
but but again democrats and media they
can't have a sense of humor about this
thing so it's very bad okay so first of
all we don't know this actually happened
because there's no tape of it that has
emerged so far it's literally just the
word of a person who's on a flight it's
gonna be really really funny if it turns
out that all the pilots had was prepare
for landing and this person was like did
he say let's go brandon apparently she
then charged up to the cockpit and
started pounding on the door which is a
great tactic by the way
that's not an faa violation at all so
but even if that's true and it could be
the reason i know it could be is because
last week i was flying and the pilot was
is a private flight and the private
and the pilot said would you like to get
on the uh on the inter on the the radio
and radio all the other pilots and say
let's go brandon so apparently this has
in fact become somewhat of a thing i'm a
pilot which is super funny
and um this is the end of the world okay
so one pilot gets on the intercom and
apparently allegedly says let's go
brandon and the media lose their bleep
they just go apely which of course is
exactly the way to get people to stop
doing a funny thing if you really want
to get people to stop doing something
make a huge deal out of it if you've
ever had children and your children have
cursed
the the smartest thing to do is make a
huge deal out of it because then they'll
they'll never do it again
or alternatively you're really stupid if
you do that
but the media can't help themselves
we'll get to this in just one second
because this is the it's great and it is
indicative again of the fact that the
double standard when it comes to
vulgarity the double standard when it
comes to how you're supposed to feel
about particular politicians is so
unbelievably glaring when it comes to
the media
first
let's talk about a simple fact you
really need to look at refining your
house like right now because the rates
are going to rise they're going to rise
sometime in the near future you should
go check out the refi rates right now if
you are a homeowner focused on your
budget it's a strategic approach
mortgage refinance makes sense for a lot
of people because rates are still near
their all-time lows and makes it a great
time to call american financing learn
about custom loan options that can save
you up to a thousand dollars a month
that's correct a month because they do
more than just lower your rate they look
at your entire financial picture finding
every way to help you save no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
so why not learn more we'll give you a
free mortgage review you might skip two
payments if you choose to move forward
you can pre-qualify for free right now
by calling
866-721-3300 that is 866-721-3300
or you can visit them at
americanfinancing.net and mls one eight
two three three four mls consumer access
dot org again right now is an excellent
time to refine your mortgage if you
haven't at least checked out the rates
you really really should pre-qualify for
free call
866-721-3300 that is
300 866-721-3300 so southwest airlines
has now released a statement and so we
know many of you have heard about recent
statements that may have been made on a
southwest flight we wanted you to hear
directly from us so they hadn't they
can't even confirm by the way that this
happened so it will be hysterical if it
turns out this is all a figment of an ap
reporter's imagination i i will laugh
very hard
it wouldn't be rare the media do this
kind of stuff all the time media are
constantly reporting incidents that are
supposedly
damning of american right-wing culture
and then it turns out that it never
happened that kind of stuff does happen
but here's what southwest says quote the
southwest team takes pride in providing
a welcoming comfortable safe and
respectful environment for the millions
of customers who fly with us each year
southwest does not condone employees
sharing their personal political
opinions while on the job serving our
customers and one employee's individual
perspective should not be interpreted as
the viewpoint of southwest and its
collective 54 000 employees southwest is
conducting an internal investigation
into the recently reported event and
will address the situation directly with
any employee involved while continuing
to remind all employees that public
expression of personal opinions while on
duty is unacceptable southwest does not
tolerate any behavior that encourages
divisiveness as it does not reflect the
southwest hospitality and inclusiveness
for which we are known and strive to
provide each day on every flight ah the
end of the world has arrived somebody
said let's go brandon on a flight ah
just just horrific just horrific okay so
southwest is apparently addressing it
internally
according to
according to the washington post the
phrase has been used as a code by
conservative critics of the president
since the chan of f joe biden broke out
among a crowd at alabama's talladega
super speedway in early october
the story also became a rallying cry for
those defending the pilot's purported
remarks with some saying it would in
fact encourage them to fly southwest
first of all that would be great
harvard professor and cnn analyst juliet
cayenne had a tweet okay so there are a
lot of tweets from a lot of blue check
mark people who are super upset so for
example expert on everything tom nichols
who writes books on expertise because
he's an expert on expertise he's so
experty that he doesn't know things so
he tweeted out
maybe for a flight attendant this would
have been okay but the pilot announcing
his political feelings with a slogan
like that strikes me as kind of loopy
if fa gets off the handle yeah but the
pilot he knows he's risking getting
fired i'm not good with trusting a guy
like that with my life
so expert tom nichols
is now worried what the guy's gonna like
fly the plane into a building because he
said let's go brand and these people are
insane i'm sorry they're just crazy
they're just crazy tristan snell who is
a person who i guess comments for cnn
that's literally the only reason anyone
has ever heard of him he tweeted
let's go brandon has become the maga
version of siege heil
oh has it i spot some differences i'm
spotting some differences like for
example i an orthodox jew not big with
the siege heil however let's go brandon
is being hilarious
okay let's go brandon is great
then you have asha rangapa who's another
cnn come i don't know what's in the
water over at cnn these people are
higher than their own supply asharangapa
she tweeted as an experiment i'd love
for a southwest pilot to say long live
isis before taking off my guess is one
the plane would be immediately grounded
two the pilot fired and three a
statement issued by the airline within a
matter of hours
long live isis
and let's go brandon again not the same
thing
like not the same thing i noticed
because
isis cuts the heads off people or puts
them in cages and sets them on fire or
you know bombs american service people
in afghanistan whereas let's go brandon
is a bunch of people who think it's
funny to say f joe biden because he's
the worst
then she followed up she couldn't let it
go and somebody tweeted back right
because supporting terrorists that have
run planes into buildings is atrocious
and not at all like saying let's go
brandon if you wore a former fbi it does
explain what's wrong with the fbi that
is a fair critique and shiro isis didn't
run planes into buildings they didn't
exist in 2001. oh well owned pawned
magga did attack the capital attempt to
overthrow the government of the united
states and threaten to hang the vice
president so oh yeah so so let's go
brandon is the same as breaking into the
capital now you wonder why the right
thinks the left is loony and these
people cannot be let anywhere near power
it's because of this kind of crap
where you suggest that if i don't like
joe biden because he's a bad president
then it's the equivalent of me rushing
into the capitol and threatening to hang
my pens
and then julia juliette kayem as i
mentioned before she tweeted if
southwest air doesn't do anything every
passenger on that flight has standing to
file a complaint with the faa and they
should do so southwest will then be
compelled to investigate or defend him
have fun with that no messing around in
the air brightline rule
and somebody wrote back not being
flipped but a complaint for what is he
in violation of an faa rule or
regulation and she said yes pilot
conduct his words reflect the
possibility of anger management or
substance abuse it is worth asking
[Music]
so now if you say let's go brandon
publicly by the way i've worn a shirt
that says let's go brandon one of my
favorite shirts a great shirt available
from daily wire
um
if you if you say that now maybe you're
on drugs or drunk while flying
okay maybe you shouldn't get drunk
before tweeting juliet kayab
ah dino badaya tweeted southwest
airlines is now the pro january sixth
terrorist attack airlines
oh
oh man again all these folks who comment
for cnn they are so crazy by the way
just a quick note here
it would be crazy right if i mean
totally nuts if it turned out
that american that pretty frequently
these airlines allow people to say
political things like say for example
that the american
american airlines crew had been allowed
to wear black lives matter pins on their
uniforms last year
which is what they did
quote american airlines believes in
equity and inclusion for all
fundamentally we believe black lives
matter is an expression of equality not
a political statement it doesn't mean
other lives don't matter rather than in
our society black lives should be
mattered and be valued the same as
others also american has already allowed
employees to wear pins representing
recognized groups including religious
faith nationality military service and
lgbtq pride flight attendants can wear
three pieces of flair on their uniform
don't worry it's it's all this is the
rule for the left it's apolitical when
they say it but so political that maybe
you should get fired if you say it and
everybody can see this crap everybody
can see it
in just one second we'll get to the
hilarity of all these folks on the left
being very upset about the vulgarity ah
the vulgarity this is what they care
about deeply now bulgaria we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let's talk about the simple fact that
the holidays are approaching and you
might be thinking about how you're gonna
save some extra money i mean let's face
it you're probably gonna rack up some
credit card charges between now and the
holidays buying christmas gifts or going
shopping for thanksgiving but what you
can't afford to do is get behind on
those credit card payments so you need
to consolidate your high interest credit
card balances to a lower rate and save
with light stream lightstream offers
credit card consolidation loans with
rates starting at 4.98 apr
with auto pay and excellent credit much
lower than the national average interest
on credit cards that's like 19 apr plus
your rate is fixed so as rates continue
to rise your low rate will not budge
there are no fees you can get your money
as soon as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience that's
exactly what they deliver just for my
listeners apply now get a special
interest rate discount save even more
the only way to get that discount go to
lightstream.com shapiro
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject credit approval rates
range from 4.98 apr to 19.99 apr include
0.50 percent autopay discount lowest
rate requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply offers are subject to
change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information that is
shapiro for more information okay so
the left is going to pretend that
they're very angry at the politicization
of anybody who's involved with the
corporation after spending a year
bullying and cuddling corporations into
doing precisely their bidding remember
the worst thing in the world is that mlb
was going to have the all-star game in
georgia they moved the all-star game
because some democrats pretended to be
offended by georgia's voter law
remember that coca-cola
made statements about this and then had
to back off of them
remember that every major corporation in
america has endorsed every woke point of
view for the last several years right
everything from
branding all of their products for lgbtq
pride month to blm
any corporate leader by the way who
spoke out about the 2020 election ripped
on trump you can't find a corp and if
they didn't like the guy who's the head
of goya he got ripped up and down by the
media so the entire corporate culture
the entire institutional corporate
culture is biased to the left because
they know where their bread is buttered
but if one pilot says a thing
on a plane bad he's probably a drunk
he's probably a drug user you gotta get
him fired really really important okay
now
are they really that concerned about the
pilot no they're concerned that people
don't like joe biden end of story okay
so then they have a second pitch okay
and their second pitch is that
anybody who doesn't like joe biden is
actually in league with january 6th or
that's that sort of crap or or must be
fired and and this is real
politicization how dare you polarize
america with your let's go brand enchant
oh the polar so that's one the other is
it's so vulgar
guys the reason we say let's go brandon
is cause it is not vulgar
okay like i'm not gonna say f joe biden
in front of my kids i will 100 say let's
go brandon in front of my kids because
it doesn't mean anything it's a
euphemism for f joe biden obviously but
that's the whole point that's why we use
euphemisms the point of euphemisms is so
that you're not vulgar it's a
deliberately non-vulgar statement but
the media are like oh
be still they're beating hearts you said
let's go brandon and we know secretly
what you mean is f joe biden and that's
vulgar it's vulgar and terrible
so you end up with with foolishness like
this from
dana milbank over at the washington post
let's go brandon is republicans vulgar
vulgar governing agenda
at 7 30 p.m thursday at 7 30 a.m
thursday morning white house officials
rolled out president biden's roughly
1.75 million trillion dollar framework
to cut taxes for ordinary americans and
make it easier for them to afford health
care and housing send their kids to
pre-k in college and adopt clean new
power for their homes and cars was that
all it does their dana millbank
he says an hour later came the
republican response from the office of
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
of kentucky he was succinct and to the
point f joe biden
technically the message a tweet from
mcconnell press secretary doug andre
showed a photo of a roadside sign that
said let's go brandon for the initiate
uninitiated that's a maga meme in which
the phrase stands for the slightly
homophonous f joe biden it's a way to
flip the bird at the president without
running a foul of technology sensors as
the right wing washington times put it
first of all it's not a maga meme
okay like it has nothing to do with
donald trump particularly
as you all know i voted for donald trump
in the last election i didn't vote for
him in the first election
guess what the new trump joe biden's a
terrible president let's go brandon just
means you don't like him
a lot of people feeling let's go brandon
right now who didn't vote for trump
which is why joe biden is in the toilet
in the approval ratings
it's why on particular issues he's down
at 37 percent like is he competent
the substitute phrase has been chanted
at rallies for virginia republican
gubernatorial candidate glenn younkin
used by senators ted cruz republican
representatives bill posie of florida on
the house floor gym banks of indiana and
donald trump jr
on thursday adopted by trump himself he
offered let's go brandon t-shirts for
those sending at least 45 dollars to his
organization save america think about
that ah
could the contrast be any greater says
dana milbank half of america's leaders
are trying to govern the other half are
hurling vulgarities oh the vulgarities
you know what's amazing was those four
years where there were no vulgarities
there were no vulgarities for four long
years when donald trump was president
america was just filled
with a spirit of goodwill and tolerance
from democrats who never had anything
vulgar to say about donald trump and in
fact were utterly intolerant of any
vulgarity directed at the president of
the united states for four years
they hated vulgarity democrats if
there's one thing democrats hate
it is vulgarity
i mean sure they're into there being no
social standards whatsoever on anything
ranging from
teaching porn to your kids in school to
curse words in music like that that's
all fine
right wap is a great song for you to
play to your seven year old but but they
are very worried about vulgarity
generally and they are specifically
worried about vulgarity that is directed
at the president of the united states
which is why they were you remember this
robert de niro he went out at the tonys
you remember and he was so you remember
the blowback remember how angry
democrats were when robert de niro said
this
i'm going to say one thing
trump
it's no longer down with trump it's
[Applause]
oh and everybody standing ovation
standing ovation from the crowd but
secretly in their heart they were upset
about the vulgarity that's what we're
led to believe they're they're literally
standing and cheering for f trump there
and the media are like uh robert de niro
what a hero i mean there's nothing quite
as heroic as standing up in front of a
bunch of people who totally agree with
you and saying f trump
resistance heroes oh you remember but
the truth is
deep down in their heart they were very
upset with vulgarity
now remember he actually said f trump he
didn't say let's go trump or let's go
brandon or let's go tony or something
okay and it wasn't just it wasn't just
robert de niro of course we all know
this okay
we were here for four years while you
use vulgarities that are
honestly unprecedented in american life
with regard to trump
like whatever you think about the
vulgarities directed at barack obama by
public figures they were nothing
compared to a public figure said about
trump and his family and anything
associated with trump his supporters
like not close not even remotely close
many of us really thought that barack
obama was a terrible president and did
great damage to the country there were
no public figures who were saying this
kind of stuff about barack obama he's
certainly not celebrated by the
mainstream media
and if a public figure was saying it he
was pretty quickly taken to task not so
on the left for four years the greatest
way to fame and fortune was to say f
trump and f family i mean you remember
samantha b literally went on air and she
called ivanka trump right not even trump
himself ivanka trump she called a
feckless sea ward
ivanka trump who works at the white
house
chose to post the second most oblivious
tweet we've seen this week you know
ivanka that's a beautiful photo of you
and your child but let me just say one
mother to another
do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
he listens to you
[Applause]
okay um yeah and and people cheering
wildly right cheering but it's the
vulgarity they have if there's one thing
democrats are known for is their
objections to generalized vulgarity they
hate generalized vulgarity
it's just the worst for them now play
that latest cardi b song again here's
jim jim gaffigan you'll remember in the
middle of august last year he wanted to
demonstrate because there are a lot of
right-wingers who kind of like jim
gaffigan's comedy for reasons that
partially elude me anyway jim gaffigan
tweeted out i don't give a bleep if
anyone thinks this is virtue signaling
or whatever we need to wake up we need
to call trump the con man and thief that
he is and then somebody wrote back to
him and he said oh fu that is moronic
but there you got me to respond idiot
he's just a
a genius and then he says remember
everything trump accuses the democrats
of he's guilty of don't let the
socialist name calling distract you from
the fact he's a fascist who has no
belief in law and someone wrote back he
probably just lost a lot of followers
for this one stick to comedy
and he wrote like hey f you karen
it just
but he was cheered for this right
heroism from from jim gaffigan oh jim
gaffigan that's what the house is
again it's
the gaslighting is insane it's insane
you want more trump this is how you're
gonna get more trump guys this is how
you're gonna get more trump seriously
because eventually the right is just
gonna be like okay we're not gonna say
let's go brandon anymore we're just
gonna say
joe biden right we're all gonna say that
we're just gonna say that because if you
say that we can't even use the euphemism
for we don't like biden without us being
accused of unprecedented vulgarity and
terrorism we're all just gonna be like
you know what screw it we're gonna say
exactly what we mean
remember that for four years wearing a
hat
a hat which was specifically supposed to
be a reference not to a cat but to
female genitals was considered a
wonderful thing it was considered a sign
of resistance heroism even npr noted at
the time that it was meant to be a
reference to vulgarity right here's npr
way back when
mcgovern acknowledges some may find the
name of the hats vulgar but i feel like
we kind of have to take it back make it
a feminist word a 2005 video of donald
trump bragging about grabbing women by
their genitals inspired the hat's
creation
deepti ceti marched with her mom and
sister all wearing the hats she says
it's empowering to re-appropriate the
word i think sitting there and saying
i'm wearing a hat
and not having it reflect something
vulgar something that you should shy
away from
okay so they were literally putting cats
on children
how dare you with your vulgarity with
your let's go brandon vulgarity
honestly off i mean
it's absurd the whole thing is absurd
okay and the vulgarity is not on the
left the vulgarity is not restricted
it's the kind of language they use with
regard to republicans it's
it's expansive that vulgarity exists in
the entire approach to america and
public life
they engage in the kind of polarizing
insane activity
that is way worse than than anything
remotely like let's go brandon hey just
to take the latest example so in
virginia it looks very much as low tariq
mcauliffe may go down to flaming defeat
tomorrow in virginia right now in the
real clear politics poll average
mcauliffe is trailing the enthusiasm in
virginia by all accounts on the ground
is not for mcauliffe the enthusiasm is
for junken by the way all the polls
nationally are showing that republicans
are far more motivated to vote in 2022
than democrats are so this early bell
weather is a disaster for democrats
so over the weekend right before the
weekend there was this picture that came
out okay the picture that came out was a
picture of five people standing in front
of a glen young kin bus they were
wearing charlottesville outfits they
were wearing outfits from
charlottesville
from the white supremacist rally like
khakis and white shirts and they were
carrying tiki torches
now it was pretty clear and they were
talking about how they supported yunkan
it was pretty clear from the get-go that
this was a phony right that it was it
was a it was an op
it was pretty clear from the get why
well because one of the people who was
carrying the tiki torch was black my
favorite thing about this
is that the leftists who wanted to make
it seem as though a bunch of white
supremacists were supporting glenn
younkin they were like but you know what
we still have to pay attention to our
own diversity requirements so we can't
just have a bunch of white guys go out
there and pretend to be white
supremacists supporting glenn young to
make young him look bad that would
violate our own
strictures and and sense of propriety
about diversity so they sent a black
dude and a lady as well
they will send this transgender little
person to pretend to be a a white
supremacist young can support geniuses
genius is all okay so this became a big
thing so on friday there are a bunch of
people on the left who are tweeting this
out look at these white supremacist
young kin supporters and everybody on
the right is like yeah this is bull i'm
sorry this is not real everybody on the
right was like this is just nonsense you
like it's pretty clear what you guys are
doing it is clear this is not true
and as it turns out it wasn't true the
lincoln project then had to claim
responsibilities you remember all those
idiots at the lincoln project who when
they are not busy covering up their
founders reaching out
i'll put that mildly reaching out to
underage men
that um when they're not busy doing that
and then disbanding then rebanding
they're they're committing ops like this
remember this was supposed to be these
are the true believer
anti-trump republicans right except they
vote for every democrat across the
country including people who have no
relation to trump so they're just
democrats who grift and grift hard
this is grift hard 2 griftarder
so they put out a statement
glenn youngkin has said president trump
represents so much of why i am running
young can proves it every day by trying
to divide virginians using racial code
words like critical race theory
the lincoln project has run
advertisements highlighting the hate
unleashed in charlottesville as well as
glenn junkin's continued failure to
denounce donald trump today's
demonstration was our way of reminding
virginians what happened in
charlottesville four years ago
we will continue to hold glenn young
accountable
until then we'll be back
okay uh so yeah it was a complete
backfire
and
i do appreciate that the lincoln project
continues to use miners for their own
perverse purposes that's that's fun
apparently these were members of the
young democrats so using young people
for their own perverse purposes and
ruining their lives is apparently like
these people will now be searchable for
the rest of time and memeable for the
rest of time that was a genius move and
this is the entire democratic shtick in
virginia right now is to try and accuse
glenn younkin of racism without any
evidence
and this is a form of political
vulgarity that really is damaging to the
country by the way critical race theory
is written into many of the standards
for the virginia department of education
chris ruffo has the receipts over on
twitter
but this is part of the pitch and the
same people are like don't say let's go
brandon to vulgar they'll go out there
and just lie about their political
opponents by calling them vicious racist
this is terry mcauliffe's game because
he's losing here's terry mcauliffe over
the weekend
he wants to ban tony morrison's book
beloved so he's going after one of the
most preeminent african-american female
writers in american history won the
nobel prize as
presidential medal of freedom and he
wants her books banned now of all the
hundreds of books you could look at why
did you take the one black female author
why did you do it he's ending his
campaign on a racist dog whistle just
like he started the campaign when he
talks about election integrity
okay that's just a lie it's just a lie
okay like this has been debunked by the
washington post it's not true but he's
going out there and he's just yelling
about how how glenn young is a racist
that's vul that's much more vulgar to me
than just saying you don't like who the
current president of the united states
is that's that is that is a slur on
character it's a slur on yonkin it is
overtly false again it's been fact
checked by people on the left it is not
true
but that sort of vulgarity
is endemic to the leftist view of the
united states more broadly
and it's really harmful like much more
harmful than you don't like the current
president it turns out pretty much half
the country at all times doesn't like
the current president no matter who the
current president is that is not the
true vulgarity the true vulgarity is
calling your fellow citizens citizens
vicious brutal racists
and then being taken seriously that's
the vulgarity okay we're gonna get to
more of this in just one second because
it's it really is
it's true gaslighting and americans know
it and it's driving the wedge it's
driving the polarization we'll get some
more on this in just a moment first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
ever since trying my pillow i can't
sleep on anything else and my pillow has
ruined other pillows for me because it's
just that good my pillow wants to give
back to our listeners right now you can
get great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com right
now click on that radial listener
special get deep discounts on my pillows
mattress toppers towels and so much more
for example my pillow right now is
offering a buy one get one free offer on
giza sheets these are top quality sheets
you will love all my pillow products
come with a 60 day money back guarantee
and a 10 year warranty go to
mypillow.com click on that radio
listeners special for the buy one get
one free offer on the giza sheets use
promo code dailywire at checkout or call
1-800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including pillow slippers the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
that's mypillow.com enter code dailywire
at checkout or
call
1-800-651-1111 tell them daily wire sent
you that's 1-800-651-1148
the deals won't last forever so call
right now again mypillow.com enter code
dailywire to get started and see what
deals are available to you alrighty
tomorrow night you need to tune in
because your very own native virginia
resident long time resident matt walsh
will sit back and watch the election
results in an exciting real-time live
stream come watch with matt over at
dailywire.com at 7 30 p.m eastern 6 30
pm central the election's gonna be
fascinating matt of course spoke at the
loudoun county school board meeting
about policies that are destroying
children's lives daily wire has broken
some of the biggest news stories of this
election cycle honestly this would not
be as close a race if it were not for
daily wire reporting if you want to stay
in the loop on more breaking news from
daily wire join right now a membership
is as little as four bucks a month and
you can get 25 off using code real news
and it was the daily wires of story
about loudoun county covering up alleged
sexual assault in its bathrooms that
broke this race wide open go check us
out right now and help us do the sort of
investigative reporting the left refuses
to do they're too busy worried about
whether southwest pilots are saying
let's go brandon join today watch with
me tomorrow night at dailywire.com
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
already so when i talk about the
vulgarity that's endemic in american
life right now i'm not talking about f
trump or f job and i'm talking about the
vulgarity of particular narratives i
mean first of all there's just the bad
treatment of people right the notion
that you can just treat people badly
based on their politics so for example
kristin cinema has been raked over the
kohl's by the radical left who have
suggested that she is very very bad
because she wasn't going to sign off on
3.5 trillion dollars in spending she's
only gonna sign off on probably three
trillion dollars when you actually do
the math four trillion dollars when you
actually do the math and extend these
democratic programs they're green
lighting over the course of actually ten
years as opposed to false sunsets but
anyway a bunch of protesters showed up
at a wedding that kirsten cinema was
actually officiating and they ruined the
wedding
and they ruined the wedding okay so
apparently this is apparently not a
national story it is a national story if
a pilot says let's go brandon
which ruined nobody's day and ruined
nobody's life here's somebody actually
trying to ruin a wedding and kirsten
cinema like comes out and she's like
begging with them please don't do this
for an hour
it's my daughter's wedding
just for an hour just let her get
married please it's this person is not
my daughter my daughter's getting
married kelly will you tell her that did
you have a
right here
okay that's the mother of the bride
comes down is begging with these people
not to ruin the daughter's wedding and
they're like
the the person officiating the water is
like
you want to know what's undermining
american life like that kind of stuff
you know what else is undermining
american life uh is the is the
generalized left-wing take on race so
colin kaepernick is just
a giant con man like one of the great
con men of our time he's a failed nfl
quarterback he had like a couple of good
seasons and then he started to fail and
so they benched him for the immortal
blaine gabbard
and then he decided it's time to kneel
for the national anthem because america
is deeply racist he wasn't racist until
he got benched then he got bench and
then america magically became racist and
he was wearing socks with pigs as cops
on them
on the basis of the lie that the police
are systemically shooting black people
for no reason
this is one of accolades he got a nike
deal the only failed quarterback to win
a giant nike deal
right with slogans saying things like
you have to risk everything
well he's risked nothing he risked zero
things he waited until he was a backup
quarterback then he knelt for the
national anthem and then the entire left
wing ran to his defense and then he
spent the last few years saying he wants
to play in the nfl while avoiding
anything that would actually get him
back into the nfl because it turns out
he kind of sucks he's not a very good
quarterback okay so now
netflix remember you're a corporate
the way the corporations work is that if
you work for southwest and you say let's
go brandon it's a firable offense but
all of netflix well netflix will just
churn out democratic propaganda day
after day after day
they'll put out propaganda with a booty
judge documentary about how he changed
the world and now we've got anna
duvernay who of course is is the woman
who has made other propaganda films
about race in the united states now
she's making a propaganda film with
colin kaepernick
talking about how colin kaepernick
changed the world it's called colin in
black and white
here's a clip from it
you want to know what ruins the country
this kind of crap so here is colin
kaepernick talking about how the nfl
combine which is a place where players
show up to demonstrate their skills in
front of coaches so that they will get
drafted higher and be paid more millions
of dollars
he compares this
millionaire colin kaepernick
compares this
to slave auctions
in this film
backed by netflix backed by corporate
bucks but that's that's not a problem
let's go brandon is a problem you know
she's more vulgar in the
broader sense of the world not not a
question here's colin kaepernick doing
something morally despicable but he's
fond of doing that for cash
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
[Music]
okay and then if you can't see this
there's a bunch of guys who are getting
checked out at the combine with their
shirts off and then they walk out of the
combine and into a graphic of them with
chains on them being auctioned off as
slaves
[Music]
i'm not kidding
this is what netflix is producing and
people bidding on them okay i can spot a
few differences one slaves were called
slaves because they were not paid
because they were literally enslaved not
they volunteered into an nfl combine
where they then got paid millions of
dollars based on their physical
abilities
but colin kaepernick conflates the two
which is more vulgar for the united
states saying that the nfl combine is
equivalent to actual honest-to-god
slavery or saying let's go brandon
but you know what the real vulgarity is
it's not that that's not real vulgarity
in sports the real vulgarity is that
donald trump went to a braves game and
did the tomahawk chop that was the end
of the world over the weekend donald
trump went to a brave skin by the way
there's great irony to the fact that
texas and georgia are the two states
competing in the world series after the
mlb decided to cave to the wokes gold
so donald trump went to uh went to the
braves game and he was doing the
tomahawk chop and this was the end of
the world okay because the tomahawk chop
is supposedly racist now if you're going
to talk about which is more racially
problematic comparing the nfl combine to
actual honest god slavery or a
non-offensive symbol at a braves game
where nobody is saying i hate native
americans therefore i'm doing the
tomahawk chop they are saying that this
is a symbol of native american culture
that we wish to co-opt because it's
awesome and they're doing the tomahawk
chop
but donald trump is the real threat to
american to american moires that's he's
the threat he's the threat
and the grift is so unbelievably strong
and this is why americans are rebelling
against this kind of crap let's go
brandon is going to become more
ubiquitous not less because it's not
just that joe biden is pursuing radical
economic policy it's that joe biden is
pursuing radical social policy is that
he is bought into a vulgarization of the
idea of america broad scale and if you
note that using any language whatsoever
this makes you bad if you note that
using euphemistic language because you
don't even want to curse
that's apparently super duper bad
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
also remember tune in tomorrow night
over at daily wire and matt walsh is
going to be live streaming the virginia
elections i'll stop by we'll have some
we'll have some chat about it i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben spiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
ibram candy accidentally disproves
systemic racism democrats send fake
white supremacists to a republican rally
in virginia and the media dubbed let's
go brandon a nazi chant check it out on
the michael knowles show